đúng người nha sử bởi người nha mùi tháng hai,
tổng thủ của quay nào vô lùi đi mẹ dưới lên khi cho biết
mì đã đất một tiêu đến tháng sau năm 2 ít không chăm hai mẹ sấu phản đặt được một thỏ thật
trong giữ chiến sử dưới rống nhà bụ quay nào,
đông thân sẽ ra tăng sự đất nếu tên trình không đáp ở Móc Thử ra này.
Cũng theo ông dên sĩ,
Washington để sốt tổ trức vòng đằng phản bà bên tiết theo tại Mỹ,
nhiều khả năng ở may mì ngay trong tổn tới,
và kia đá xong nhận tham gia,
Mỹ muốn hoàn tất tiền trình trước mùa hè trong bối cảnh các uống tiền trình trình
nói vô bao gồm bầu cử giữ những gì đang đến gần.
Tuy nhiên các vòng hoạt nào gần đây trong đó của cuộc gặp tại Abu Dhabi
chưa có kết quả khu thế,
ngoài thảo thật xa đổi bá trong mối bụng tuy bình,
đối bên,
hiện ngà buộc quay nào bất bất đồng số sắc về lạnh thổ đồng bá s và quyền kiểm soát
nhìn biển hành cho gia đình gia buổi dạ.
Ui quay nào khẳng định không chấp đặt giúp quân khỏi các vùng gặp kiểm soát,
sau xong bối nữ lưng ngoài rau,
ngà tí tục tập kích hả tận năng lượng quay nào,
buộc những nhà may điện hành cho phải giản công xuất,
làm gia tăng thiếu uống điện và sửa trên gia gió trong bối cảnh mô đông kháng nghiệt.
Trong một dịch viên quán,
cùng ngay mùa hảy,
giá hoàng liệu mối bụng cùng italiá đã kêu gọi ngà bụ quay nào
ngừng bắn trong thời gian gia thêm hoạt ordinate phức mô đông,
miệng lần đầu có tin à,
phía u quay nào nhìn mạnh,
sẵn sẵn tổn thủ nếu ngà có cảm kết tưởng,
sòng mắt sửa vạc không phần hồi.